hello and welcome to this video playing
birds or girls with an English like okay
the proper we do is c5 yeah f3 Bishop d6
us a line that I had on the board number
of times people somehow have problems
handling that really I just said is a
bit odd yeah beautiful yeah it's still
tougher how do you how does that play it
again e5 that's a chick
check on before and then you take this
is not good for white at all but well
the last time I looked at that it's like
two years ago maybe more than two years
ago when I did when I produce my Banco
repertoire and yeah it's always
difficult to remember of course why
displaying instantly and doesn't really
care
it seems what's going on he's already a
decisive material down just wonder if he
has something miraculous now to save him
I cannot Castle that is some an issue
but I mean why do I just is totally not
coordinated
um Bishop eform might be on the cards
him
oh maybe just 96
and I can take a tool or see four heads
both it's both possible okay
he has to probably play Bishop b4 now
and not sure it castles I go Queen d5
that's over so he has to do something
else here is not threatening to take
really because b1 is also hanging but I
probably have to move my rook rook b8
maybe hey what castle so I have to do
this
what's my dear Queen a5 Queen c7 okay
where's that better than canceling out
because it was hanging high okay just
this one I guess for Queen c7
yeah maybe Quincy father
maybe 94 then
it's a bit annoying really I can return
the exchange and be a pawn up but I'm
not sure if I'm winning the game then
that's the problem
yeah just for practical reasons let's do
it okay he will play rook to be one
sorry rook to e1 it's very likely I'm
not going to hang on to the material but
rather try to be active okay I'm not
sure if I should go as five you know you
know probably something like that is
more active he can take them he can do
that I mean I'm not really encouraged I
have to should be five at the end
maybe he can just about play this it
looks completely terrible and the night
has no squares but might just be working
because my bishop is also hanging in
some lines like in Aichi one root chakra
he had this for example it looks
completely rotten but if I go here he
will take it and that is probably just a
draw and it's just a drawing I have to
do it I have no time
it's still very dry still is wrong it
wasn't drawers before I was of course
totally winning at some point but okay
well maybe he's making a couple of more
mistakes
but even that you can probably stand and
not be totally lost
yeah at least in this book ending I can
play quit moves that is useful
kingi for you should prevent King a five
I think okay
yeah it was a bit stupid when I did
problem
[Music]
yeah I mean I should just win out of the
opening but it wasn't so easy from a
practical point of view this is not good
for white the whole thing this c3 I
should just use I think this takes takes
97 is stronger okay 97 is stronger
probably because I'm just quickly
playing a would be a gem could be like
like this instead if he now plays this I
have would be aid and I'm winning
yeah possible so this should also win
but it's what's getting a little bit a
little bit tricky especially with the
time yeah and now I decided to return
the exchange which is actually basically
what the engine also wants to do
you know and now this is probably going
to be an ending in the drawer it's
active enough this the engine is not
really criticizing anything and we are
still within the drawing range even
after you blundered upon with everything
on one side of the board it's just and
now Luke age a gem now it should be lost
I think I wonder ever spotted
this is spoiling it six rockers and yeah
because he can now get over here yeah
look it's even more strange I think you
should just check on it only to when the
engine says it's a draw I wasn't really
totally sure with with no time our
tiered should be it should be yeah yeah
that's an opening opening thing the
funny differently discussion now
okay thanks a lot for watching